[Musique]
c'est en conférence de presse que le
département présente la nouvelle
délégation de service public qui sera en
charge des théâtres départementaux de
2023 à 2029 la collectivité souhaite
mettre en place des actions culturelles
plus territorialisées 25% de la
programmation portera la culture hors
des murs la culture au sein des théâtres
départementaux bien évidemment nous y
tenons mais ce que nous avons prescrit
au nouveau prestataire c'est aussi de
s'ouvrir d'aller vers les Réunionnais
parce que beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne
viennent pas dans nos espaces
de théâtre et nous convient madame et ça
c'est un mouvement très fort la future
programmation s'ouvrira à
l'international tout en valorisant les
artistes locaux 60% des dates leur
seront réservées le nouveau délégataire
run music s'engage également à proposer
3000 heures chaque année dédié à
l'insertion par l'activité économique
dans ces clauses il y a une obligation
pour le dégataire de faire un certain
nombre d'heures d'insertion par an c'est
dans le marbre et le légataire a préparé
un projet qui répond à ces critères de
clauses d'insertion il y a même la
clause
environnementale c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce
qui vont mettre en place pour respecter
le développement durable dans les
pratiques quotidiennes etc pareil le
délégataire a présenté un projet qui
était vraiment performant le département
engagera également des travaux de
réflexion de ces deux théâtres pour un
meilleur accueil du public
et des artistes le théâtre de
Champfleury et le théâtre plein air de
Saint-Gilles vous proposeront très
bientôt de nouvelles affiches pour faire
vivre la culture au plus près des
Réunionnais
[Musique]